it's insufferable you can't turn on any
program especially on Netflix they've
switched the genders there's always like
the token black person the token Muslim
person or like the token woman and in
reality it's just not going to be like
that like I was watching and I might get
stick for this but I was watching a new
Netflix series but the main character is
a Muslim Brown woman she's a police
officer and she's fighting this it's
just not realistic realistically it's
going to be a white man in London the
United Kingdom is majority white it's
not realistic if you look at the
probability of how realistic it is this
one superhero to save the whole of
humanity is that really going to be
Brown Muslim wom it's unlikely
statistically speaking if you look at
the makeup and the demographics of the
United Kingdom it's going to be a white
man is that a bad thing no but they just
make it a woman so they can be woke and
it's really annoying